[Musique]
ce sont des confidences qui font froid
dans le dos tant par leur honnêteté
rares et sans détour que par la triste
réalité qu'elle révèle alors qu'il a
quitté nos écrans évincé de france
télévisions il ya peu patrick sébastien
reste pour autant toujours très présent
dans les médias et comme à son habitude
l'homme ne cache pas grand chose de ces
combats à son public
récemment c'est sur son addiction à
l'alcool que patrick sébastien s'est
confiée une addiction dont il a réussi à
se sortir il ya déjà trente quatre ans
je buvais un litre et demi de whisky par
jour sans faire attention car au départ
c'était festif
je suis devenu alcoolique un alcoolisme
qu'il a su stopper à temps j'ai arrêté
le jour où je me suis rendu compte que
les emmerdements dépasser plaisir et il
faut toujours s'arrêter quand les
emmerdements dépasse le plaisir des
addictions qui ne sont malheureusement
pas si rare chez les artistes
on se souvient notamment de jean luc
delarue qui avait reconnu être accro à
la cocaïne ou encore de johnny gérard
depardieu renaud mais aussi véronique
sanson qui ont dû faire face aussi à 2
conséquent problème avec l'alcool
si par chance certains d'entre eux ont
réussi à surmonter ses addictions ses
stars ont eu besoin de se confier au
public sur ces moments de faiblesse
alors selon vous drogue alcool
dépression les stars doivent-elles
parler de leur combat alors c'est vrai
que ça fait énormément parler ce qu'on
vient d'apprendre sur ces dernières
stars ces derniers jours donc plusieurs
artistes ont parlé de leurs problèmes
d'alcool comme patrick sébastien dans
nice matin encore l'humoriste jérémy
ferrari
il a expliqué qu'il a même fait une
tentative de sully la scène s'est passée
dans un hôtel à aix en provence
j'étais très très haut si je sautais
c'était fini mon meilleur ami est venu
au moment où j'étais sur leurs bords les
dernières semaines avant la tentative il
m'arrivait d'ouvrir une bouteille de
rosé le matin de la boire au goulot
j'ai toujours su que j'étais alcoolique
c'est un témoignage très fort un de
jérémy ferrari
est ce que vous pensez et je vous pose
la question avoue aussi que les
célébrités doivent parler de leur combat
benjamin castaldi
oui bah oui bien sûr parce que je pense
que quand on s'en est sorti c'est un
modèle pour les autres
moi j'ai moi dans ma famille ma grand
mère a eu un penchant pendant des années
pour pour la bouteille et c'est vrai que
quand on est dans cette situation là
c'est très compliqué parce qu'on en fait
on n'ose pas en parler on se cacher on
se ment à soi même et nous on avait cru
que ma grand mère on en était même à un
moment donné a remplacé le whisky à
moitié part de l'ol sort des plus
content mais elle a pris la décision de
s'arrêter plus jeune femme et après la
pluie ont parlé mais a beau on n'en
parle jamais donc on devient un exemple
pour les autres ça très bien le faire
parce que c'est un exemple c'est je
pense un espoir pour ceux qui sont dans
la merde et qui n'arrivent pas à
s'entendre c'est un poison et l'alcool
et la drogue avait déjà parlé
franchement de quoi vous êtes déjà
confié sur quelque chose vous pas du
tout c'est angoissant la langue à
l'école
donc moi j'ai pas j'ai pas d'addiction
moi je
un coup c'est vrai c'est à tomber mais à
une certaine période quand j'allais pas
très bien où est un peu un peu l'alcool
mais vraiment pas voilà pas un bavoir du
rosé au goulot mais c'est effectivement
pour le coup pour les gens connus très
souvent c'est un échappatoire évidemment
alors qu'un artiste qui a beaucoup
souffert de sa dépendance alcool serre
dont il en parlait avec beaucoup
d'émotion chez michel drucker et après
on va voir quelqu'un du nom parti qu'est
ce qui fait qu'un mada du nez
d'immanence alliés je repars à jour
grand corps malade est venu me trouver
j'étais encore sous l'emprise ces
boissons anisées et il m'a proposé ce
soir son album que j'ai fait les écrire
c'est une zone fallait les chanteurs
mais c'est du mal au début tu allais
infinite johan hamilton pour arrêter de
noir parce que ma voix était en roue et
enfumée par force ci a été victime et
par beaucoup de pastis beaucoup trop un
livre par jour et suis sorti de la
retaper et arrêter de boire depuis ici
aujourd'hui ça fait six mois et 20 jours
et mes enfants
voilà renault puis embrasse fort que
j'aime énormément un rondo alla il le
sait mathieu d'armes pour 6 ne faut pas
en parler mais pour trois raisons la
première c'est que j'en ai marre de
penser que quand les gens connus doivent
être des exemples ce sont des artistes
mais ce sont des hommes
donc on n'est pas un exemple on n'est
pas ça m'agace à chaque fois qu'on doit
que je prends un autre exemple mais met
au pas dans la voie des bus fais pas ça
tu dois être un exemple vous êtes des
artistes vous avez un métier
vous n'êtes pas un exemple on n'a pas
valeur d'exemple deuxième chose je ne
connais pas une personne qui essaie
c'est quelque chose suite à un livre où
suite à une confession de quelqu'un pour
moi c'est nist pas du tout j'adore
patrick sébastien mais j'ai arrêté de
boire il ya 34 ans je vois peu de
personnes tout d'un coup au truc que
j'ai jamais entendu quelqu'un tout d'un
coup se dire j'ai arrêté de boire tels
que patrick sébastien
arrêtez de boire ya 34 ans mais pour moi
ça n'existe pas non plus et troisième
chose je suis de la vieille école encore
peut-être un vieux con mais j'adore les
artistes et gère les stars et j'aimerais
bien ne pas trop les connaître - les
connaître j'adore encore le côté ou et
adjani ou vittel que fait-elle est-ce
qu'elle souffrait d'autres pas j'en ai
marre de cet étalage dans la presse de
tout ça je n'ai pas envie de savoir
je suis très triste pour gérer mais
ferrari qui me fait rire est tout ça je
vous ai pas eu envie d'avoir cette
confession qui me glace dans le dos et
qui m'intéresse pas tellement
donc voilà pour ces trois raisons la non
non les artistes se gardent leur mal
comme les com comme les autres et
arrêtez de s'étaler en permanence et
c'est pour ça qu'ils présentaient pas un
people en fait les gosses il a aussi
fait dissipées gossip ou huit ans jamais
quelqu'un une fois par les bons 7,9 et
non au jour un scoop à un menu on rigole
voyez-vous la produisent et ses
émissions de divertissement quand on
parle on ne parle pas de ces sujets là
et on en rigolerait pas autour d'une
table de la drogue je peux pas leur dire
tu viennes en hiver une énorme bêtise
une énorme bêtise j'ai lâchement j'ai la
chance ce mois par an ce moment d'être
de faire pas mal de salon du livre et
j'ai je partage les tables avec des
justement des sciences que du som
d'embêter comme van der des deux
vedettes qui font des livres justement
testimonio ce qu'on appelle et moi je né
vois les files d'attentes des gens avec
le livre sous le bras qui viennent
parler justement à la vedette en
question pour dire vous m'avez aidé
alors soit c'est le déclic
soit ces emplois de chemin soit c'est un
effet miroir mais en tout cas vous
m'avez aidé donc rien que pour ça rien
que pour ça
ça vaut le coup qu'ils aient eu besoin
de raconter aussi parce qu'il ya l'effet
miroir ils existent pour de vrai alors
le témoignage le plus fort qu'on ait eue
sur ce thème là c'est quand même de la
rue il avait dû avouer publiquement son
addiction à la cocaïne ça c'est vraiment
cité historique 1 regardez son
témoignage c'était dans complément
d'enquêté en 2011
c'était une consommation lourde à la
fois dire oui aux très lourdes
c'est à dire ah bah c'est énorme à la
fin à la fin c'était à peu près 20
grammes par semaine
donc ça paraît patiné grave mais c'est
beaucoup de drogue quoi d'après ce que
m'ont dit les policiers ce n'est pas
fréquent c'est pas non plus rarissime
c'est existe quand on arrive vraiment au
bout de la consommation de plus pouvoir
s'arrêter le produit fait quasiment plus
d'effet donc on apprend beaucoup plus
quoi il soit on peut pas s'arrêter quoi
moi c'est fini à vie l'alcool c'est fini
à vie à l'europe c'est fini à vie les
médicaments je n'ai pas le choix sinon
je meurs c'est une question de vie ou de
mort pour moi oui
l'armée qui oui mais moi oui zabel jean
luc chatel mon ami moi j'ai beaucoup
souffert de le voir et comme célérité
aux amis de le voir se droguait vous le
saviez vous le saviez j sur toulouse
avait créé sur tout mais on le savait
d'autant qu'à vd les médicaments aussi
la pub pour se réveiller la pilule pour
dormir aurait pu lui pour tenir le
public pour tous les médocs pour tous et
moi comme je l'aimais infiniment
ça m'a vraiment fait souffrir et après
il a éprouvé mathieu le besoin de la
rédemption il à ses quatorze mille
kilomètres en vain et il a fait tout ça
avait de façon frénétique comme le reste
il est allé dans tous les villages et où
il a discuté avec les drogués avec les
écoles dans les lycées il a fait un
véritable travail de rédemption là
dessus que l'arrêt des malades a dit non
je voudrais répondre à valérie qui en
fait en voulant brillamment défendre le
camp du oui a donné une telle victoire
au camp du don de soi lorsque pourquoi
leicester et salon du livre à nous peut
être descendre
non mais c'est vrai sujet moi avec tout
mon respect pourquoi est ce qu'il ne
faut pas en parler c'est pire parce que
là vous parlez de stars qui en fou
commerce commerces qui vendent librement
c'est fini est ce que j'aime c'est le
jeu la file d'attenté au salon du livre
pour acheter un livre c'est pas gratuit
un livre d'accord donc ils font colère
de leur maladie foucault maire de leurs
malheurs moi je trouve qu'à une
indécence canton nesta on peut avoir des
problèmes mais en parler comme ça et
vendre à la presse ou dans des livres
son malheur pour moi ce n'est pas où 10
pour tous les gens qui eux ont des
addictions je vais qui souffrent et qui
ne gagnent pas ces fortunes alors il y
aurait un autre témoignage fort que je
vous montrais c'était celui de pierre
palmade
il était venu parler de son addiction à
la drogue chez laurent ruquier regarde
je ne savais pas à 20 ans que c'était
une maladie je pensais que c'est un
divertissement je subodorais à 30 ans
que c'était un poison à 40 ans j'étais
sûr que j'étais cocaïnomane et que
j'allais dans le mur et ça fait dix ans
que j'essaie de d'arrêter et à chaque
fois je me dis c'est la dernière fois
c'est la dernière fois alors je peux je
serai dépendant à vie mais je peux être
abstinent toute ma vie c'est à dire que
si j'évite tous les pièges je peux à
partir d'aujourd'hui est depuis trois
semaines en tout cas je peux ne plus
jamais en prendre de ma vie si je me
démerde pas trop mal jean-michel ouimet
les riches eux et je suis entièrement
d'accord ici mais je ne respecterai ce
genre de livre testament you que le jour
les les gains des recettes des livres
sont versées mais ce sont comme des
alcooliques anonymes
je suis désolé mais quand tu te sens
seul et que tu penses que tu es seul le
monde à souffrir et que tout d'un coup
tu as une vedette que tu crois en eau
tout en haut du firmament qui a une vie
géniale qui te dis bah je suis même
merde que toi ça te fait du bien au
moral
c'est tout et que tu te dis bah lui
aussi tu vois quand renault qui s'est
épanché sur le fait qu'il avait arrêté
il a replongé à l'instant t matthieu
delormeau maintenant et aux autres
choses très important c'est évidemment
c'est au jeune comparse et surtout à gré
sur tout l'axé de touche et
malheureusement ça je dois entendu plein
plein plein de fois ce qui se passe
c'est que justement comme il voit
souvent des vedettes parler de drogue ou
d'alcool
il voit pas forcément les mauvais côtés
mais l'arrivée non je te promets que
c'est vrai ils disent c'est un peu un
truc de rockstar c'est un peu marrant
elle a un peu c'est s est un peu les
mecs connu son lot dès qu'ils ont réussi
donc quelque part ils s'assimilent un
peu ils disent si je le fais d'autres le
font elton john se droguait ça va c'est
elton john myv donc oui je suis désolé
quand tu es jeune tu est à 6101 par les
mecs qui réussissent prenez pas de
drogue
pas très nombreux dont je suis marois
jonathan je connais court qu'à la télé
qui en fumée tout s'écoule ces machins
mais bien sûr on ne sait pas cool quand
au moins 8 muster et pc bien toutes ces
dames à 14 ans l'ebitda pas 14 oui oui
c'est fabien pailler m'emporte si son
idole sophie travail dol fut juste
content
sophie koch mal du tout d'accord avec
toi match d'abord tu as parlé d'
exemplarité tout à l'heure où il m'a dit
bon voilà les people n'ont pas être des
exemples balayer racontent leurs
déboires donc je vois pas où est
l'exemple à arrêter au contraire si
puisque c'est chiant que dirais tu
parles cela avait connu un boom et a
disparu
j'en suis sorti sur wii ils sont en
train de raconter leurs déboires leurs
difficultés justement à sortir des
addictions vie raconte leur victoire a
durci en fait seulement mais au
contraire mouvman en regardant ses dires
nous avons reçu ici sur ce même plateau
dans de quoi je me mêle les missions des
cno lors aux la chanteuse rose qui a
écrit un bouquin formidable savez le
kérosène où elle raconte mais sa
descente aux enfers c'est à dire que
voilà elle a eu la de l'acfo cocaïne
l'alcool mais l'alcool à haut niveau
pareil enfin bon je limite elle buvait
le parfum la cocaïne les médicaments etc
elle est venue raconter donc dans son
livre le livre victoire d'affilée il m'a
fallu que la minute
c'est pas ça dit qu'il m'avait sorti non
écrit je me l'étais quand julie série la
jamaïque a jamais au caté écrit quand tu
es en plein dans le don le truc mais si
la technique enfin j'ai vaincu la drogue
au werder mais c'est fou cette naïveté
du camp d'en face vous est terrible
avant vous accumulez les poncifs flammes
et je vous signale que quand vous
travaillez dans l'édition
ouais aller voir un médecin travaille
dans les disques durs à côte avant
direct un vrai travail dans les options
oui tu m'expliques le fonctionnement des
décès parler quand on va voir un éditeur
il vous dit tu veux raconter ta vie tu
as quoi à dire voilà ça va on vendra
rien n'y a pas eu des problèmes d'alcool
ta paye des problèmes de drogue si vous
avez fait combien de bouquins 3 pourquoi
croit c'est sur quoi papa son ca bastia
sur quoi rester pas dans un bio il y
avait là sur 4000 exemplaires
oui mais pourquoi tu dis ça mais moi
j'ai pas les beaux que j'ai fait le
premier j'avais pas du bien de moi ça me
va je voulais raconter mes grands
parents américains par bourg-en-bresse
qui vous vous demandez si vous aviez des
problèmes sur la dernière bio vous avez
fait salle où vous mettez plein la
gueule des billets dans les jeux vous
étiez assorti d un autre nom mais non là
je les écris parce qu'effectivement j'ai
expliqué pourquoi j'aimais faire tout
est dans la merde
mais là où vous dites une sérieuse
métissée que concernant les stars
généralement quand elle n'écrit pas
invoquer voudrait qu'elles ont raison
vaincu cesser ces dix là elle meurt
parce que le corps comme une idée mort
parce que mes moyens
elle est morte parce que tous à son bord
il meurt ils n'ont pas le temps de le
dire
effectivement c'est rare mais on écrit
pour ton âme je filme la mer les gens
s'expriment très bien sûr le sur le
sujet dont je reviens du show band ont
choisis ton camp je n'ai pas envie de
bouger donc je suis dans les non non je
trouve que c'est très con cernant je
pense qu'effectivement quand les gens
quand les gens entendent des stars leur
star parler de ça quand il quand il voit
que les gens s'en sortent alors qu'il
eût dans des conditions parfois pénible
voilà les gens font un transfert et se
disent qu'ils peuvent aussi s'en sortir
donc je suis partagé c'est patent de
parler des ventes est ce que c'est bien
ou pas de faire un livre là-dessus
c'était pas ça le thème le thème c'est
déjà d'en parler ou ne pas en parler moi
je crois que de partager je pense qu'on
s'identifie et je pense que ça aide
dans ces domaines là et dans plein
d'autres domaines comme adil à la meuf
qui va au salon du livre alors chérie je
voulais vous dire un truc aussi sur sur
moi perso parce que moi je vois plein de
gens aussi sur twitter qui disent ouais
hanouna chaussures qui prend l'eau
qu'ils boivent ans les émissions qui
prennent un coup
question tout en vrai c'est vrai tout le
monde fasse porter à venir vers nous
c'est vrai tout le monde dit ça je vous
le dis c'est vrai que j'en vois plein
sur twitter des abrutis même qui disent
ouais les ravages de la cocan je me mets
de l'eau alors si j'en trouve à je vais
je suis je un jour j'entamerai pour moi
et je veux avoir les ravages dans sa
gueule
messoudi mais ce que vous savez je suis
très sympa mais bon voilà je peux de
mètres séparent les chéris non mais
c'est vrai que ça me ferait résout et je
vous le dis je le dis aux jeunes qui me
regarde parce qu'il ya beaucoup de gens
qui me disent aussi c'est vrai qu'il ya
beaucoup de jeunes qui tu regardes et tu
sais moi je vous dis je pense qu'on peut
vraiment s'éclater et être agité tout le
temps sans alcool sans drogue sans moi
je moi je suis même pas une cigarette et
c'est vrai que voilà je le dis et je
pense qu'ils sont là pour témoigner sa
fait un oui l'année qui travaillent avec
moi moi je n'ai jamais touché à rien je
n'ai jamais même pas fumer un joint dans
ma vie benjamin qui me connaît bien mais
là n'est rien du tout et rien voilà même
en soirée
je me dis je bois jamais un verre
d'alcool ni alors je dis pas que c'est
peut-être un peu chiant non mais c'est
vrai peut-être voilà non parce qu'il ya
des mecs qui des matières loubon un
petit maire mais je suis déjà tellement
agité et moi si je suis tombé dedans
quand je suis testé à jeudi alors voila
moi je pense vraiment qu'on peut
s'amuser autrement prête attention
rentrait pas là dedans je vous dis la
vérité parce que c'est ça fait vraiment
des ravages et norma on est d'accord
mais benji il est vrai que ces extraits
vous avez une addiction
je veux dire c'est quoi la bolivie que
framboise et là ils achètent bien pour
défaut béton des fossés tu manges tu
manges man voilà ça tu manges tu bois
des sodas tu leur as tu manges et pizzas
et ça tu manges de la merde c'est vrai
les filets au sud les filet o fish et
les machins ça tu manges - mais ça aussi
c'est grave aussi ça c'est un concert
les vaches dans les artères qui se
bouchent mal à ça c'est moi demain la
nourriture et tout ça sera pour donner
le spectateur tient les chèques 71 de
leurs combats 78 30 % dont